[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir il s'en est fallu de très peu
j'ai tiré au sort en fait pour décider
de venir vraiment ou pas ça fait un peu
peur aux organisateurs et on a eu de la
chance sur ce coup là enfin peut-être
c'est important cette histoire de
prendre des décisions en se donnant la
possibilité du oui ou du non
c'est important et je vais vous
expliquer un peu comment tout ça m'est
venu
mais avant j'aimerais que vous fassiez
une chose est ce que vous avez à portée
de main une pièce comme celle là une
autre
vous pouvez y aller je voulais
demanderait pas à la fin juste que vous
ayez une pièce dans la main pendant que
je vous parle cette pièce là cette
question là elle m'est venue parce que
j'ai de la chance j'ai la chance d'avoir
trois fils qui sont intelligents sportif
et qui aiment lire
et puis j'ai de la chance aussi beaucoup
parce que je fais au quotidien ce que je
rêvais de faire quand j'étais enfant je
passe une partie de mon activité à
écrire des livres
mais il se trouve que les livres que
j'écrivais quand mes enfants étaient
plus petits ils les intéressait pas
vraiment et il avait bien raison de pas
s'y intéresser
en l'occurrence mais c'était frustrant
de rien écrire pour je voulais écrire un
livre pour eux et je voulais écrire un
livre qu'ils n'auraient pas lu par
ailleurs il me fallait une idée une idée
qu'il n'allait pas trouvé dans un autre
livre
cette idée elle m'est venue un soir en
marchant dans une station balnéaire
je marchais et d'un seul coup ça m'est
venu les idées arrivent comme ça
j'aurais pu attendre longtemps et je
serai pas là pour vous en parler encore
un peu de chance sur ce coup là l'idée
était simple c'était de raconter une
histoire qui se passait dans un monde où
toutes les décisions chaque décision
importante était prise en tirant à pile
ou face
c'est quelque chose qui m'a semblé
riches
de potentiel riche parce que c'était une
façon d'expliquer aux lecteurs et à mes
fils en premier lieu ce que c'était que
de se poser des questions ce que c'est
que de se demander si on va faire une
chose plutôt qu'une autre
et comment est ce qu'on doit se poser
ces questions une fois que j'ai écrit ce
livre est ce livre existe il est là
s'appelle hainaut la chasse aux rastas
qu une fois que j'ai écrit ce livre je
me suis dit bon c'est bien d'avoir une
idée qui me semble original à moi mais
je vais quand même aller vérifier que
quelqu'un l'a pas fait avant donc je
vais aller voir un peu ce qui se passait
en fiction sur le même thème en fiction
il ya plein de choses
vous avez des dès 1930 de 31,32 scarface
dans lequel un des personnages passe son
temps à prendre ses décisions en tirant
à pile ou face
ce personnage là on le retrouve dans
d'autres oeuvres sous d'autres formes et
parfois qui n'ont rien à voir
dix ans après 1940 de batman rencontre
un super méchant qui aura une carrière
aussi longue que la sienne
ce super méchant c'est double face qui
légitiment ces meurtres en tirant à pile
ou face
et puis vous avez ça le même type de
méchants le même type d'assassins dans
no country for old men des frères coen
plus récemment ok c'est pas un ressort
dramatique principal mais s'attache à un
personnage si on va chercher de le rôle
du hasard on trouve une nouvelle
formidable d'isaac asimov 1 la machine
qui a gagné la guerre dans la machine
qui a gagné la guerre qui est une
nouvelle assez courte
trois personnages discutent ces trois
personnages discutent de la façon dont
la guerre a été gagné le premier de ces
personnages est celui qui donnait les
informations à l'ordinateur les
informations et puis ensuite il ya un
deuxième personnage celui qui va
interpréter ce que l'ordinateur lui dit
à l'époque les interfaces n'était pas
aussi évolué qu'aujourd'hui fallait
interpréter
et puis un troisième personnage celui
qui va donner les ordres au fil du
dialogue
et je m'excuse pour ceux qui l'auraient
pas lu je vais absolument tout spoiler
au fil de dialogues on s'aperçoit que le
premier des personnages donner de la
cohérence aux informations qui
soumettait à l'ordinateur ça lui
semblait pas tout à fait judicieux de
faire autrement
le deuxième personnage celui qui
recevait les informations de
l'ordinateur corriger des choses qui lui
semblait pas tout à fait logique non
plus et le troisième avait pas du tout
confiance dans cette méthode est pour
prendre ses décisions plutôt que de
suivre ce que l'ordinateur lui disait y
tirer à pile ou face
c'est comme ça que la machine à gagner
la guerre ça doit pouvoir aussi nous
faire réfléchir sur l'intelligence
artificielle
cette histoire là vous vous dites c'est
de la fiction très bien mais en fait
quelques années après une étude a été
faite sur des bulletin prévisionnel
établi par des experts de wall street à
l'aide de très très gros ordinateurs ou
des milliers de bulletins qui ont été
étudiées et on a regardé si les
prévisions des prévisionnistes s'étaient
avérées exactes
ou pas les prévisionnistes avaient
raison dans 47% des cas 47% ça veut dire
que s'il avait tiré à pile ou face
il aurait obtenu de meilleurs résultats
c'est intéressant ce qu'on peut faire
avec du hasard il ya eu plein de petites
choses comme ça
1 ça c'était mes gars de wall street
on passe dans le sport il y en a bien
deux trois qui suivent le foot tous les
matchs de foot puis dans un certain
nombre de sports d'autres le tennis etc
commencent par un tirage au sort
l'équipe où le joueur qui va avoir le
ballon
aoun a pas un avantage selon l'état dans
lequel il est etc mais on a bien un
élément de hasard au début de chaque
match
celui là était un peu particulier 1 le
vouvoyer leurs beats qui se penche là
ils se penchent parce que quand il a
lancé la pièce il lui arrivait quelque
chose qui n'arrive à personne elle s'est
fichée sur la tranche il a été obligé de
se baisser pour recommencer
mais ça c'est le début du hasard dans le
sport il ya quelques autres cas plus
rigolo plus intéressant 1936 les joueurs
de ping pong connaître connaissent cette
date un match dur championnat du monde
le match dure 7h35 c'est très très long
7h35 de ping pong mois au bout de 20
minutes j'en peux plus donc je visualise
même pas très très bien ce que ça peut
être
et au bout de sept heures 35 y avait
toujours rien à faire avec les deux
joueurs qui n'arrivait pas à se
départager on leur a dit c'est bon vous
arrêter là maintenant on tire à pile ou
face
et c'est comme ça que le champion du
monde a été désigné un peu plus près de
nous 1968 là c'est les amateurs de foot
qui connaissent 1968 on est en demi
finale de la coupe d'europe italie urss
et à l'époque aucun service cerveaux
brillants n'avait imaginé les tirs au
but
donc au bout de 120 minutes le match en
est à 0 0 et là les deux capitaines les
arbitres descends descends vont ils
partent c'est très frustrant pour les
spectateurs manifestement je suis pas
sûr que j'étais né mais pas loin et
et donc ils vont tirer au sort dans les
vestiaires l'italie est désigné
vainqueur de la demi finale et l'italie
gagnera la coupe d'europe en finale donc
on a comme ça des moments où le tirage
au sort a un impact sur la réalité
ok c'est du sport en politique en
politique dans un certain nombre de pays
quand deux candidats arrivent à égalité
dans un vote on tire au sort en france
on prend le plus vieux je sait pas du
tout quelle est la meilleure solution
c'est pas que des petits pays un ca se
fait aux primaires aux états unis donc
il ya il ya toutes ces toutes ces
circonstances là puis d'autres encore
plus petit moins importante vous savez
peut-être pas pourquoi on dit hewlett
packard des papas cardio ou bête
hewlett et packard sont les fondateurs
de l'entreprise et ils ont tiré au sort
le sens c'est l'ordre dans lequel on
allait mettre leur nom à un portland
s'appelle portland
parce que on a tiré son nom le nom de la
ville au sort plus dramatiques parfois
est chez nous et partout et dans
d'autres endroits
un jury de cour d'assises c'était bien
des gens qui sont tirés au sort et le
hasard fait pas toujours bien les choses
on va retourner un peu dans le monde de
la fiction avec ce livre là le l'homme
des de l'udc rheinhardt l'homme des
c'est un livre culte pas forcément un
best-seller mais un vrai livre culte
dans ce livre l'auteur raconte
l'histoire d'un homme un
psychothérapeute qui s'ennuie un peu
dans sa vie de tous les jours et qui
décide de remettre son destin entre les
mains de dés pour savoir ce qu'il va
faire il va tirer au d ça commence assez
tranquillement l'aider lui disent
simplement s'il peut ou pas trompé sa
femme avec la voisine
ça va de plus en plus loin et ça va très
très loin
parce que à chaque fois on va tenter des
choses un peu différentes c'est ça aussi
le hasard
oui c'est un livre sauf que ce livre il
a été pris au sérieux par un certain
nombre de gens donc vous avez des gens
qui prennent ce livre très très au
sérieux et qui mènent leur vie comme ça
pas forcément des gens complètement fou
richard branson le pdg de virgin s'est
retrouvé un soir dans un concert en
finlande parce que l'aider lui avait dit
d'aller écouter le concert en finlande
ou et l'aider lui avait aussi dit qu'il
fallait qu'il crie très très fort le
plus fort possible à toutes les heures
fixes donc il s'est mis à crier très
fort à 22h au milieu d'un morceau très
très calme
ce garçon pèse 5 milliards de dollars et
il doit avoir pris une ou deux décisions
autres comme ça ça vous fait peut-être
réfléchir à tout ce que vous pouvez
faire avec la pièce que vous avez dans
les mains vingt cinq milliards de
dollars
bon lui ça se termine pas trop mal un
journaliste ben marshall s'est vu
confier par son rédacteur en chef la
mission d'appliquer la méthode de l'udc
rheinhardt aller pendant trois mois tu
va tirer tout ce que tu fais aude et
donc le journaliste a dit oui ok je te
faire un beau reportage avec ça il y va
et il a poussé la logique jusqu'au bout
donc il s'est injecté un mélange de
cocaïne et d'héroïne parce que l'aider
lui avait dit que c'était quand même une
axe ses bonnes idées
je ne sais pas si c'était avant ou après
avoir conseillé à sa petite amie d'aller
faire du strip tease à los angeles
il a fini par aller en prison mais je
crois que son reportage était pas mal
donc voilà il ya des conséquences
réelles et il se passe des choses quand
on quand on laisse un peu de place au
hasard évidemment dans hainaut la chasse
aux rats stack que j'ai écrit pour mes
fils j'ai fait en sorte qu'ils ne
terminent pas leur vie
en s'injectant des produits licites puis
en allant en prison et j'ai essayé
d'imaginer un système qui permettrait de
faire les choses au hasard tout en ayant
une société qui fonctionne ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'il ya un certain
nombre de règles
en plus du fait de lancer sa pièce pour
chaque décision
la première des règles c'est qu'une fois
qu'on a posé une question on n'a pas le
droit de la reposer sinon c'est un peu
facile
oui non c'est parce que je veux je
recommence ne s'en sort pas c'est la
première des règles
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut faire
très attention à la façon dont on va
enchaîner et poser les questions
alors là pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont
quelques souvenirs de mathématiques du
lycée
ça va être assez clair pour les autres
il faudra réviser un peu mais vous voyez
bien que si le système judiciaire
consiste à lancer une pièce pour savoir
quelle peine on va appliquer à un
condamné
si la première question que je pose
c'est est-ce que ce type il est condamné
à mort oui non le gars a une chance sur
deux de s'en remettre
par contre si je pose la question
différemment si ma première question
c'est est ce que on le combat est ce
qu'on le condamne à une amende si la
réponse est oui le type écope d'une
amende et c'est fini si c'est non on va
poser la question suivante
donc après la mandia la peine de prison
après la peine de prison
le bannissement l'amputation et la peine
de mort donc ceux qui sont forts en
maths
là ça veut déjà combien il a de chances
de mourir les autres noms mais c'est
beaucoup moins qu'avec la première
solution
donc les gens qui posent les questions
qu'ils choisissent l'ordre dans lequel
on pose les questions et la façon dont
on les pose dispose du pouvoir
le fait est
que du coup on est obligé d'avoir une
caste de personnes qui vont savoir
comment poser les questions et
l'ensemble est totalement hiérarchisé de
façon à ce qu'ils aient pas de
débordements le truc c'est que les
premières questions et permis de
répondre à peu près intelligemment et de
manière soft aux questions aux grands
principes généraux d'organisations de la
société civile droit de tuer mon voisin
cambon ne chante quand je pose la
question on est mal donc comme c'est mon
roman
je me suis débrouillé pour que ça tienne
quand même un peu avec les questions de
départ sinon c'était mal engagé mais est
ce que finalement ce monde dans lequel
on s'en remet à la d'une pièce pour
prendre une décision et moins rationnels
que le monde dans lequel nous vivons est
ce que vous savez exactement pourquoi et
comment vous avez décidé de venir ici
et est ce que vous pouvez être
totalement sûr que si une pièce vous
avez dit nanan attend va faire autre
chose vous passeriez par une meilleure
soirée
j'avais promis de pas aller jusque là
pour les suivants mais ce que j'espère
maintenant c'est que ça fait un quart
d'heure grosso modo un gros quart
d'heure que vous m'écoutez avec une
pièce dans la main je me dis normalement
que veut vous vous êtes dit qu'ils
avaient peut-être une question que vous
pouviez poser à cette pièce là et que
peut-être demain ce soir alors pas tout
de suite
par exemple vous ne demandez pas tout de
suite à la pièce si vous quittez la
salle
non c'est très important il faut pas
remettre les choses en jeu tout le temps
mais demain posé juste une question à
cette pièce là vous savez on l'a
peut-être tous fait à dos enfin les
garçons je vais lui parler ou je vais
pas lui parler à la fille
tous jouent là
et j'ai aucune raison rationnelle de le
faire ou pas le faire donc j'ai qu'une
chose à dire
ce qui est important c'est pas forcément
les réponses c'est la façon de se poser
les bonnes questions
merci
[Applaudissements]